in the first two weeks after russia's
invasion the eu received more refugees
than in 2015 and 2016 put together what
was the eu's immediate response as
russian aggression continues more and
more people will seek shelter and
protection but how are eu member states
preparing to share responsibility
after years of political deadlock will
this provoke a change of heart among eu
governments when it comes to asylum and
migration policy in the eu let's look
into this in this new episode of what's
left
[Music]
[Music]
my name is natalie
i am ukrainian i live in kharkov
i used to live in hacker i wake up
at five o'clock in the morning because
it's really big sounds
outside my window firework or somewhere
and i understand it's not a firework it
was very dangerous for my
child and that's why i
take him and my mother and we
came here
more than one week ago my sister buy
us a ticket to
plan a plane and we came here
escaping war
in the last weeks millions of people did
so
some arrived here in brussels by car bus
or taxi as they could
searching for safe heaven
fleeing shelling and russian artillery
people now have to wait in line
i'm from ukraine from kyo exactly from
kiev then we
have lived in the village named zasky
but
it's too scary
we decided to go here it was so hard to
join
here to
to get to this country can you tell me
what you're doing here i'm waiting for
registration for me and my two childs
and for my sister what i need about this
registration is the school for my
children because they
so confused of all of this situation
[Music]
with the russian aggression on ukraine
neighboring countries opened their
borders then in a historic gesture the
eu granted immediate protection and
working rights to ukrainians activating
the temporary protection directive in
other words the eu opened its arms
it's good that we activated the
so-called temporary protection directive
so people are allowed to come
the children are allowed to go to school
the adults are allowed to look for work
but you don't need this asylum procedure
at least for one year it can be
prolonged
and then we have to see how the
situation develops beyond the much
needed immediate response of the
european union and the member states
it's at a grassroots level that ordinary
citizens throughout europe opened their
hearts and their homes to people fleeing
ukraine they helped by volunteering
providing a roof over people's heads
making generous donations sending first
aid products
a resident of bosnian in poland mikawai
stepped up early on we decided to buy
things that we need like first of all
was clothes medicines stuff for soldiers
blankets sleeping bags
flashlights stones and stuff like that
we didn't even think about it taking any
bulletproof vests or helmets we just
went in and went a bit further than
weave when we actually went there it
happened and people were actually
thanking me because no one was bringing
stuff inside the ukraine everything was
stopping on the european union
mostly there was super surprise class uh
thank you
giving me hugs and then the last round
is with people who are bringing into the
poland usually my hometown which is
poznan i'm focusing on getting people
job place to stay
and
all the necessary things they need i
decided to
help because i thought that helping
makes us human beings it was just a
quick thing in my brain
with my adhd which actually helps with
that kind of stuff so don't worry
this is an unprecedented situation not
seen since the second world war in
europe with a humanitarian situation
worsening by the power in ukraine most
refugees have fled to hungary moldova
romania and slovakia with poland bearing
the brunt of the crisis poland and
moldova say they have already reached
full capacity will there be others in
the same scenario
in belgium authorities seem to have
reacted quickly but there's still a lot
to do
on france
the early steps in the integration
process are crucial but while we are
still in the midst of a pandemic our
governments prepare to offer the support
people need
of course we will need money our
communities local levels have to be
prepared for schools and other
infrastructures and that's something
where member states have to offer things
but also the commission is ready to use
all the funding that has not been used
is still there from the army from the
cohesion funds and also to need some
flexibility measures so to ensure member
states get the support they need
[Music]
now we have to go on another step also
to make sure that on european level we
will have a solidarity and also coherent
approach because we can tackle this much
better together than just to leave it to
some member state and all this has to be
done in a coordinated way and we also
have to make sure that we don't have now
new models of exploitation
of these people that come in a desperate
situation not in a very good bargaining
position maybe on a labor market maybe
also lacking language skills this is
something we need to address and this
will be the new level of help and
support that is needed
is this a turning point for europe's
asylum policy how will what's happened
in ukraine affect the debate
and the policies in the fact on asylum
and migration that the european
parliament is currently working on the
countries to the welcoming refugees with
open arms like hungary poland and the
czech republic were the first ones to
reject the principles of solidarity when
the european commission presented draft
laws on sharing responsibility in 2020.
long before that some governments
steered her postal anti-migrant
narrative for political gains
under the new laws the temporary
protection directive will be replaced by
a crisis regulation this would make sure
the eu is prepared when there are large
influxes of refugees and would guarantee
no country is left alone to deal with
the consequences
we need to keep true
and faithful to our standards so that we
provide humanitarian assistance
for ukrainians fleeing the war for sure
but also other human beings which are
not to be neglected
or discriminated against
the way we treat ukrainians must be
extended to other situations which are
comparable people fleeing from conflict
zones from wars it is the case of
syrians it is the case of iraqis it is a
case of afghans it's the case of
elections they should be treated
likewise
and i only hope
that this momentum
will be brought
precisely
to raise awareness as to what solidarity
really means in the european ideal if
you look at poland if you look at
romania what people did there is is just
fantastic
but we cannot leave these countries
alone because we can already see that
mayor say sorry we did everything we
could but we need more help
i really love my country we have a very
very beautiful town i live in the center
of the city and i now i watch
the videos and photos from kharkiv and
it's
incredible what happened there is
it's ruined
really really i don't know
maybe
sometimes
later
we
[Music]
can
again
to build our city but now it's
in it's a very bad way
i'm sorry
whenever a large number of refugees flee
a country of course there can be
specific situations to address
for example with so many women and child
refugees fleeing ukraine and many
unaccompanied minors we are urging the
eu to respond with a child protection
package to give specific support
but our response to refugees must always
be based on solidarity no matter where
they're from or the color of the skin
now we need to make the most out of the
change of heart and make solidarity the
rule not the exception
you